EMERGENCY AWESOME
Hey YouTubers it's Charlie.
So this is going to be my Game of Thrones Episode 3 Video.
So, so many WTFs we have to talk about.
I think we got a good picture for where most of the action is going this Season.
So, just careful for SPOILERS if you haven't seen the episode yet.
And, new round of the give away all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
So here we go.
Starting with Number 5.
Arya learns about the inner workings of the House of Black and White.
Including that she needs to leave her life as Arya Stark behind.
It was really heartbreaking to see her hide Needle.
I think that we can all expect that by the end of the season, she'll probably go searching for that again.
The whole idea behind what Jaqen is trying to tell her, is that
she has to leave her previous identity behind.
She can't be Arya Stark anymore. She has to be "No One."
So, this will be her new costume for the next couple of episodes
She'll go through a couple costume changes this season.
They already showed off what her new costume will look like in the promo images.
It actually looks pretty cool.
Who else recognized Faye Marsay from the Dr. Who Christmas Special too. As the waif, that's who she's playing.
The game of "Faces" looks an awful lot like a slap fight.
That's just where they practice shifting faces.
The idea is, is that once Arya gets good enough, she can just shift faces at will.
But, that's like years and years of training away.
When Jaqen was talking to her in the temple about there being one god,
"a girl knows his name," she was taking about the many-face god.
And his gift, his gift is the release from the burden of life.
The gift of death, basically.
That man that she saw taking the cup of water who said "Valar Morghulis."
He was actually coming there to die.
He was the same man that they were embalming at the end of the episode.
I don't want to get too crazy into spoilers.
There are like several levels in the House of Black and White,
as you go lower, it get cooler.
Trust me.
In the next couple of episodes we'll probably go down to the next level
where you'll find out exactly what happens to those bodies once they're done with them.
Moving on to Number 4.
Brienne agrees to train Podrick as a knight.
She says that she can't knight him.
But that's only because she's not a knight herself, a Lord or a King.
Otherwise, she could have done it on the spot. She could have just made him a knight.
It's really touching to listen to them explain their back stories too
Brienne explains the story about how Renly was really nice to her,
when the sons of other nobles were being mean to her as a child.
Her father wanted to marry her off.
So he created this ball, and invited a bunch of Lords with their sons.
But they all just made fun of her the whole time. Except for Renly
Podrick on the other hand is a Payne, so he has close ties with the Lannister family.
So Tywin spared him when ever his former knight that he was squired to was killed.